you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
is the genetic code really a code
it is a code it's definitely a code and
it is a code that's put together not by
a designer but by natural selection it's
very easy to see how that can happen in
principle details of course need to be
worked out but nevertheless there is no
problem in saying that dna would be a
code in just the same kind of way as a
computer code it certainly is a code
you can read it as a code you could you
could even transcribe i think i put this
in river out of eden you could even
transcribe a book
into
dna letters and you could read it out
again you could preserve it in dna
that's that's how code like it is it
really is completely code-like code a
digital code it's merely quaternary
rather than binary and of course it's
not put together by design it's put
together by natural selection
yeah
yeah i think
maybe the best way to go about this is
to just try and talk about what
information is in general i mean
or we could talk about we could talk
about computer code in general too
because
that
one of the things i think a lot of
people in my generation have difficulty
understanding
we think of code as this magical thing
because the computers that we have are
basically like they work like magic to
us
smartphones are
so far beyond our comprehension that we
can't make sense of them whereas when
you were first working with computers
things were a lot more mechanical how
they worked was a lot more obvious
maybe maybe talking about your
experience with that would be helpful
well it's true that i when i've
did in in my career i have had a sort of
rather misspend youth
and part of that was writing machine
code programs with machine code programs
you really are very close
to the hardware
um you're you're writing in assembly
language which is
uh just one removed from writing down
ones and naughts and you have to be very
familiar with the ones and also you're
very
uh acquainted with the idea that it
really is is digital that's well there's
a piece of computer tape which is very
familiar to me because when i first
started
uh computing um we did everything on
punch paper tape like that in america at
the same time they were using punch
cards same idea
but in britain we had we had um which
british computers had patch paper tape
they really were right down there
among the digits among the binary digits
from the naughts and ones
and got a very clear conception
of the relationship between writing a
program and actually
putting notes and ones into the computer
you could even correct errors by
changing a one into an order like
literally punching an extra hole
in that tape or even sticking a bit of a
bit of tape over a hole that shouldn't
be there
that close to it i didn't even know that
these things existed until uh maybe a
couple of months ago i started looking
this up i got i was so interested in the
similarity between
these old punch tape computers and the
ribosome
because it's reading uh it's reading
this a lot like messenger rna you know
you've got uh
you know each
what what do you call this um
each
byte
here is um yes
that's that that's an 8-bit
tape i think yes yeah um i was i was
using first of all five bit tapes and
then eight tapes yes that's right
in a way tape is better than cards for
that analogy because
cards are discrete objects if you drop
them on the floor it's a very bad thing
i discovered when i went to america and
started having to use punch cards um but
tape is much more like dna because it's
because it is a long a long string
um and and so the the analogy is even
closer in a trivial sense of course i
think that maybe that's one of the
reasons that people have difficulty
understanding the link between the
genetic code and computer code is
because
you know
that basic machine code language is
none of us experienced none of us
interact with that anymore and it
actually made me think i wonder if
if dna hadn't been discovered right
after you know we were breaking codes in
world war ii and then
when people were using stuff like this i
i wonder if it would have taken us
longer to figure out the genetic code or
if we ever ever even would have if we
discovered dna at the wrong point in
history you know interesting yes that's
an interesting thought
um
and you're right of course that nowadays
since we're a little bit further away
from the machine code level
uh we're accustomed to dealing with
computers at a higher level
where we're dealing with whole programs
um and um it's almost as though
the computers are sort of human i mean
we talk about
it it thinks it's a so-and-so or or um
it it thinks it's talking to the wrong
kind of printer that's that kind of
thing we use we use
metaphoric language like thinking
um which is
at a higher level that's rather suitable
actually for
understanding perhaps how the brain
works
but for understanding how jeans work
um the
punch paper tape metaphor is perhaps
a bit more
suitable
so that was just a clip for my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below i just want to point
out a couple interesting things there
first off yes it is very obvious that
the genetic code this thing that we call
a genetic code it is equivalent to
machine code in computers the only big
obvious difference is that the genetic
code evolved and machine codes were
invented by humans
in the entire conversation dawkins goes
on to talk about how there are other
things in genetics that represent higher
level coding so the the genetic code
itself is just
basic machine language so the zeros and
ones basically that you would find
inside of a computer and if you're
interested i also have a video on how we
think the genetic code itself evolved
the other thing i want to point out that
was that that i loved here is that
richard dawkins refers to his misspent
youth
playing around with computer programming
i thought that was funny well it's true
that i when i
did in in my career i have had a sort of
rather misspend youth um and part of
that was writing machine code programs
with machine code programs you really
are very close
to the hardware
subscribe to this channel if you enjoyed
it
i upload clips pretty regularly talks
and conversations and presentations that
i've done on genetics and evolution and
i am gearing up to start doing weekly
videos again here that are completely
new completely fresh so yeah subscribe
and like and comment and all that jazz
if you want